[Music]
in no more Monday's news
why what's wrong with Monday we're
getting rid of it why do people like
mouths like Mondays I don't like my New
York Monday that anymore no cuz then on
Sunday I can't wait to get back to
getting busy you're like not relatable
right no no no it's cuz he likes what he
does I guess are missing only so far you
played this on Tuesday it's [ __ ]
Thursday right I forgot
I'm gonna keep it I just found it in my
kitchen the leader card when we right
okay okay I remember I don't like Monday
at school that's for sure
oh then this is part of this story here
we go submitted by Pepsi or coca-cola
unless Pepsi pays me to say otherwise I
might do on that and they have that's
true Bart's a pretty good brand
ambassador for Coke because I was a
Pepsi person I [ __ ] love coke but a
Pepsi pays me I love Pepsi - it's like
you pay me I'll change this label out
any time yep a school district has axed
Mondays after deciding to cut the school
week down to four days
I mean colleges like pretty much four
days here's a question for you guys
would you guys rather have Monday's off
or Friday's off Friday Friday Monday
what why you don't know what you're
saying I do take it back
think about it either start my day and
then work on a Friday yeah I'm fine with
that
but then you know that Thursday it's all
it's like you're done that's so sick
that's the same you know on Sunday you
don't have to wake up early I don't I
think both answers are all right they're
pretty strong answers Monday you know
you have to wake up earlier
met my bachelor that way okay so I used
to have Monday's off basically cuz I
would work on Sundays and it's the same
it just replaces the feeling of Sunday
so then you feel like Tuesday is like
the new Monday oh really
but no one's free on Monday but I like
going to the malls cuz there's no one
there okay that's good Friday there's a
lot of more people who take the day off
on Friday think about this are you ready
for this no okay so Thursday night you
get to have Thursday night and then you
wake up Friday morning and it's Friday
night so you get Thursday off and then
Thursday night is you'd like you can
hang oh is that where it is me yeah oh
that's what it is you spoiled yeah sure
Thursday's Jake a muse actually Thursday
night is my war so like literally right
after this right now actually after this
oh my god you spoiled so of course
you're biased towards Monday well she
works on Monday right exactly so they're
going out of four days a week was their
school day longer it is okay it is
longer Oh longer I don't want to put my
children through school that's that's
[ __ ] on like two ish yeah three ish
yeah then now they're saying oh it's
going to like five ish you guys could
have put your kids in school yes what's
wrong with me what are you gonna do do
you remember how torturous it was we had
to go through it they gotta go no one in
the rest of the world functions on that
schedule I feel like the biggest reason
why I hated school was the [ __ ]
hypocrisy how inefficient it was and how
[ __ ] dumb it was no but you learn
skills that aren't related to the
subjects like time management like
getting assignments done on time like
social skills like all those things
important I know a lot of kids that have
shitty social skills that still went to
school throughout their whole entire the
statistic is higher with homeschooled
yeah it's [ __ ] way higher dude those
kids are [ __ ] up as how that against
education and learning
I just want to reform the system because
it's so [ __ ] up well I mean there is
I wish I could do that homeschool kids
develop like [ __ ] those cold like
sweaty hands oh thank you you know the
monitor I can think of it he has warm
sweaty hands something I don't want my
kid to be oh I'll give you that they're
warm I don't want like you to be Jaden
Smith but that's not what they do
dude oh they just place them in
different learning environments so that
they get stimulated in different ways
and it's not so systemized the way
public school is does that support that
side of my point sounds pretty cool -
yeah oh I wish I went there Mike you
wish I could have worked but I think in
that was expensive it's 40,000 a year
damn what oh [ __ ] my kid is anything
like me he's gonna she or he is gonna
have a horrible [ __ ] time in school
if it's anything like Jess perfect you
know what's crazy your kids gonna come
out like nothing like both of you in the
middle yeah and you're gonna be like I
have no [ __ ] clue what to do well if
they're balanced then they'll be fine in
school if it's anything like my mom
great anything like my grandma okay so
it's just a wall of dice then hey do you
like my dad anything like my brother
wait I don't know
the whole world operates on that
schedule and also everyone's gonna be
talking about like making references to
school your whole life and you'll never
understand what they're talking about
that's how you make a Jane Smith my
cousin it's a crazy to YouTube his
parents are diplomats and then they
travel all over the world and went to
different skews any oh wait he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] up never mind
alright so this school district we're
talking about it thanks for those six
minutes this is in Colorado and there's
the school district
Aspen no oh so they're saying that
they're all there are already this is a
tongue twister
there's ow everywhere there are your
shoulders ham getting higher and higher
I'm like trying to get out almost done
Tiff's 560 school districts in 25 states
are already allowing certain schools to
switch from Monday to Thursday schedule
you know that sucks film Thursday no no
actually I'm like Tuesday to Friday
whose day to Friday I'm sorry but you
know what kind of sucks toys now I feel
like all those parents gotta find the
baby I was thinking as a parent I was
like no I can't have it yeah because
that makes it tough for the parents
exactly what they're saying here come on
especially for low-income families it's
even harder because then how are they
gonna find child care and like for their
own work like just even if they can't
find childcare then how are they gonna
take afford to take that other yep money
it's awesome no problem I got it baby
whatever and then not only that but the
low-income kids they rely on public
schools for both lunch and dinner all 5
days out of the week so if you take one
day out of that and drugs to us with the
other drugs from - wait what's that one
from school
oh sure you can't get drug like that at
home that day they want to get the drugs
from but this particular school district
they're saying that they want to be able
to save money so they hope to save
around 1 million dollars in three key
areas by not rent so one of them is by
not running school buses on the days of
no classes and by doing that they will
save her around $700,000 this is in
Colorado yeah
where are the tax dollars going yeah
that's what I was thinking because
enrollment gets more funding because the
government pays you every single time a
student is an absent and I've been
making the hell of money off we Palawan
yeah maybe there's the school funding
works differently I don't know
they're also saying that they save money
by not hiring substitute teachers and
from utilities costs that's pretty weird
I don't know I don't know I don't get it
maybe maybe because I don't know how the
[ __ ] inner workings of a school
economics work like but to me it just
doesn't sound right because of all the
extra problems that will be caused by
that free day yeah it would be a blast
for the kids but then the parents like
what the [ __ ]
I'd rather know my kids at the school
yeah yeah well they are saying that they
haven't had any teachers say that it's a
bad idea I mean that you just probably
want the day off
they actually wouldn't be getting it
though well they would but one Monday
out of the week they have to go in why
do we have to work so [ __ ] much just
to [ __ ] fork out a normal living
because both parents have to work
full-time jobs and then the kids are
just like sitting there being programmed
to do the same thing right and the
teachers have to pay out of their own
pockets even around a lot of these
supplies it protects money going they're
doing more
[ __ ] yeah bottom water they're doing a
comparison of how much things cost today
relative to even our parents generation
and then their parents generation and
you can see like homes they went up
[ __ ] crazy
and college like university like how
much they caught us up over here no
matter what the only thing that goes up
every year no matter the [ __ ] what yeah
I think it was like in two years salary
or something that that could have taken
care of someone's a complete university
experience but now it's like [ __ ] man
two hundred thousand or whatever yeah
even it's not even the stock market goes
like this even housing prices it goes
like this the [ __ ] price for
admission to college always baby oh the
sweetest racket running that's so true
and four other degrees that you needed
just a bachelor for now it's like you
need masters you need PhD yeah yeah like
physical therapy just like in the 90s or
whatever you could have had a bachelor's
and then started practicing but now you
need a master which is so silly because
you learned more being on the job
getting on-the-job experience is always
worth more in the field but that's all
racket that's what I'm saying there's a
school racket that's what I'm saying man
yeah
while I'm sane I agree what you would
say safe school industrial complex
doorknob yeah so this district they did
mention that they will be offering child
care services on the day that the kids
won't be in school but that will cost
$30 a date who's paying that the parents
that's [ __ ] up that's what it'll offer
it but you stuff to pay kids to pay
attention that line to from like 8:00
a.m. to 5:00 p.m.
kiss got a DB that's crazy I could have
wait till it was three o'clock I would
just be looking wait so if you have
multiple kids in school 120 a month each
geez look if you're a Mormon
you're [ __ ] yeah well you're not
living in Colorado thing thankfully I'd
be [ __ ] pissed it's been a long time
since I was in the public school system
but I feel like that [ __ ]
crushes Souls it's crazy because this is
dis trending 25 states by 160 school
districts they're already doing this
what about all the successful school
districts they're not doing that I bet
you what's Irvine doing they're doing
more school six days a week
[Music]